i think everyone is a freedom fighter i
get this question asked a lot i think
that we are all born with the innate
skill to freedom fight i think that some
people choose to
really dig deep into that and some
people choose to not
[Music]
alexandria butler thank you so much for
being with me on my show 20 minute
leaders how are you
i'm good thank you so much for having me
how are you
i am fantastic thank you i'm very
excited to have you on the show because
it's always
incredible for me to speak to people who
are so passionate about a multitude of
things and i'm excited to both
dive deep into your experience as a
program manager at facebook airbnb
most recently now twitter also a
stanford graduate but
i'm even more interested to hear about
you as a freedom freedom fighter
and that's not something that i see on
linkedin every day
as a title um let's start with that
what is what is being a freedom fighter
so i think everyone is a freedom fighter
i get this question asked a lot
i think that we are all born with the
innate skill to freedom fight
i think that some people choose to
really dig deep into that and some
people choose to not which is really
unfortunate
and so how i define freedom fighting is
just seeing something that is wrong
and taking the steps whatever steps and
privilege that you have
to try to change it and so for me as a
black woman in the technology industry
and coming from stanford i never wanted
to go into tech if you talk to anybody
that i went to undergrad with
i'm sure they're still laughing that i'm
in the tech industry um
i just sort of stumbled into it
with this idea that i'm gonna be here
for a year or two
as i figure out my life and then i'm
gonna go do something else
and i realized pretty quickly that i
actually really enjoy it
but there were all these gaps one being
very young
being 22 and not knowing what's going on
and really not
having access or not having a leadership
that really understood this concept that
at 22 regardless of what college you go
to
you know nothing about life and what
does it mean to bring in new college
grads
and say okay so we know that we employed
you but we also know that
we need to build programs that help you
figure out how to adult
101 right and so that was really my
first step of freedom fighting was
that's where
the gap was for me at 22. i felt like i
had a job
i worked i had management i had people
that worked around me that were showing
me how to do my job
but nobody was showing me how to be an
adult and then i would start talking to
other people at my company that were my
age and they had the same
issue so i said okay so why don't we
just require
leadership to give us those skills
either a give us those skills
b give us the time to find those skills
or c
give us money to bring in people to
teach us those skills
and so i went to the head of engineering
um for the company that i was working in
because i was an engineering program
manager
and he knew me somewhat and i said i
need ten thousand dollars to start a new
college grad program
because we don't know what we're doing
right and he said okay sure and remember
in the tech industry 10 grand is
actually not a lot of money
and so i used this skill of mine which
was asking questions
and just kind of walking and
interrupting spaces and saying but this
is what i need
um to really bring together the new
college grads that i was working with so
at 22 that was my freedom fight
and then as i got older i recognized
that i have another freedom fight and
that's being a black woman in the tech
industry
um as a black woman who was raised born
and raised in st louis missouri
i completely understood blackness i i'm
very aware of that and
um i'm honored to be a black woman i
think it's the
best trait about me um is this womanhood
and this connection
to something as beautiful as black
american-ness yet i'm also aware that i
live in a world and live in a country
that that's very
polarizing and can be very political and
people think certain things of me that
really
just fundamentally aren't true um and so
walking around
the tech industry i was one of my own
there were there were other black women
but either a they were much
older than me or they did not work in
the same department that i did
and so i said okay we have to fix that
because i need to figure out how
i'm going to rise up the ranks i need to
figure out how i'm going to do well at
my career
and in order to do that i need
mentorship from all different types of
people
but there are specific conversations and
specific
understandings that i can really only
have with black women
and so i started a facebook group called
sister circle black women in tech in
and just invited black women who work in
tech and um
to go to brunch and now we have over
seven thousand women all over the world
wow you're with yeah we partner with
tech companies
to start really having these important
conversations and these important
conversations are not just
dni focus diversity and inclusion
focused i always tell people
black women do not need to be preached
to about diversity and inclusion like
we already know that's an issue but what
we do need
is we need to have conversations about
how we level up in our career because
people usually exclude us from those
conversations so whether it's
partnering with a tech company and
having a negotiations workshop or
partnering with another company and
talking about how do you go from an
individual contributor to a manager
and things like that so how do we grow
ourselves so we
are not only prepared for the next step
but we
know how to funnel this magic that the
world has given us
um in the best way so yeah that's what i
do you know what
what's so inspiring to me with what
you're saying you know so a lot of the
time when i hear about you know
people that are passionate about you
know diversity and inclusion and i'm
personally
obviously very passionate about those
topics myself but a lot of the times
it's very general and and it almost
seems like i'm talking to people it's
like
well what can i do as an individual
person right and what impact can i have
and all of a sudden here i'm hearing you
talk about
this very specific idea that you had
how can i help black women in tech
support each other ate each other
get tech companies to come and give us
these negotiations workshops and classes
and help and create a supportive
community and i can't i can only imagine
the amazing impact you've had on those
thousands of women and and the lesson
that i'm taking away from
this is you know we're all you know can
we can all have an impact in our
immediate community we don't have to
you know it's not an all or nothing game
which is to be really inspiring
and that's what freedom fighting is
right because i always tell folks my day
job is not diversity and inclusion
i happen to be a black woman who works
in an industry
that there are not a lot of black women
i happen to be a black woman
who lives in america and has received
some of the most
egregious oppressions that you could
ever imagine because of what i look like
and so therefore because of those
experiences i'm also very aware of how
i will will and will not be
whether i am at work or whether i'm at
home
and so what happens when i stand in that
power
even when i'm at work not even talking
about sister circle but talking about my
day job
and talking to my manager or
having conversations with my co-workers
because that's freedom fighting
as well right being in a room and
helping builds a product and raising my
hand and saying hey
are we thinking about black people when
we as we're doing this
hey have you thought about how that may
affect abc community
hey so i noticed that this room is
somewhat diverse but it'd be great
if we had this type of person in the
room to give this perspective because i
know i can't give that
and i know all of you can't give that
and we need that perspective before we
launch this product
and that is really what freedom fighting
is it's this intentionality
to say that like i don't have all the
answers so i either a the answers that i
do have
speak up or b the answers that i don't
have speak up and literally drag the
person in the room
that i think has the answer or knows the
person who has the answer
because that's what diversity and
inclusion really is it's just
being the person in the room that says
something's not right
so if all i have to do is just go find
the person to fix this
i have no problem sending that email how
do we make this a norm
so not every company has in alexandria
working for her and obviously looking at
your incredible lineup of amazing
companies that you've that you've
supported
it shows what you're bringing to the
table but so what what can
every you know startup that's that's
growing or every company
what can what can we do to make this
more of a norm to keep having this
mindset of
can we can can we think critically about
who's in this room who are we
representing
who are we supporting on the other side
and who are potential customers that we
might not even be thinking of
i always tell people to recognize your
own privilege right um
you know it was funny i was joking with
the co-worker last week about this
and i said i find it interesting that
people refuse to deal with their trauma
but instead want to put their trauma on
me which makes no actual sense
right so deal with yours and then come
talk to me and and to me what that means
is that
in order to be that person you have to
know yourself fully
and to know yourself fully you have to
recognize your layers of privilege
in any given situation you have the most
privilege in the room
you may have the middle or you may have
the least unfortunately because of white
supremacy
we identify people based on what they
look like
but as we all know everybody comes from
a story
so there's lots of privilege that you
may not see when you physically look at
my body right
whether it's i you know whether it's you
have a person that comes from poverty or
whether it's you have a person
that did not grow up with mom and dad
right like
you you may not physically see that one
themselves but that is a lack of
privilege
and i think people need to really do
this work so a couple years ago
i started this workshop called the
privilege workshop which i've been
doing with a lot of companies and groups
of people to say
hey let's just here for the next two to
three hours and figure out what your
layers of privilege are
because i fundamentally believe that if
you can identify your layers of
privilege
if you can say hey this is my gender and
because of its gender it is either a
layer of privilege or it is not
this is my race and because of this race
it is a layer of privilege or it is not
this is my educational background i know
this is a stanford
um stanford platform and i always tell
folks that i went to stanford university
and i have to own that privilege
i went to stanford university which is
an elite institution that i'm very proud
of going to
i'm not going to apologize for my
degrees
but at the same time i'm also aware that
it is a privilege and most people don't
have that privilege
and i'm also not going to sit here and
pretend that i don't know
the privilege of going to a school that
helped
build the industry that i work in
like there's layers here you know what i
mean it's like it's like going to
an ivy league school on the east coast
and working on wall street there is a
privilege there
because we all know wall street many
people from those east coast schools
have funneled and fueled right that
workforce
so i can't sit here as a stanford grad
working in the technology industry to
not
accept and identify that privilege
whether or not
i speak it out loud but that is there
right and
once you identify your privileges if you
can identify your privileges then you're
also at the same time acknowledging that
they exist
and in that acknowledgement you're
acknowledging that also other people
don't have those things
and that's what we all need in these
workspaces is people to acknowledge
what's in front of them do not make
excuses
for it i get very tired of people making
excuses for their privilege
because most of the time privilege is
not something that you did to yourself
it's things that this it just happened
this way it's like a deck of cards
um but honoring that privilege by saying
so this is what it is and
how can i give back to people who don't
have that privilege
so for me for example how do i give back
to people
as a black straight woman working in the
technology industry with
two stanford degrees how do i give back
to people
well one um going back
going back to stanford and helping
stanford kids and advising
but also to making sure that i'm talking
to other students who did not go to
stanford
so how can i help you and let's have
these conversations
that i'm very aware that i was having at
18 19
20 years old at stanford that other kids
may not have had right
um or have had but never had a techno
technological lens because stanford is
very techy
right um and so that's what i think we
all need to do and if we all do that
work
of getting to know ourselves better then
when you walk into professional spaces
you then know yourself then you can also
be aware that like oh so this person
doesn't have that in this moment
so how can i just give it to them for a
few seconds
right i love it alexandria what you know
a lot of these things are
you know in you know we we have to look
into ourselves and and recognize and i
think
very critically especially in 2020 you
know i lived in israel my most of my
life i
came to california this past year to
start stanford and all of a sudden i'm
hit with this polarized
you know area where i'm i'm
understanding that there are these
deep-rooted conflicts
which may have been you know brushed
under the rug from for some people
although obviously for many others it
hasn't been
and all of a sudden there's this all
whole uprising of polarization of 2020
and i'm becoming very conscious of it
myself but what is one thing
that every person that listens to this
including
myself and my friends can do tangibly to
to help to help make things a little bit
less polarized
and help really understand that you know
some of us come from a more privileged
background and help those that don't
stop stop assuming that your story is
the single story of human
of humanness and human hood if that's
even a term it should be a term if it's
not um
stop assuming that your way of life
and your way of thinking is either the
only way
or the best way right um
when we are born we come into this world
with so much stuff
a lot of that is trauma that is given to
us from our parents
and our ancestors not our faults but it
is there and you have to acknowledge it
a lot of it is blessings and prayers and
hopes
that come from the same people a lot of
it is the environment in which we live
in
a lot of it is religion right what what
religious texts have told us
and i always tell folks i think religion
is
is so beautiful i love learning about
different religions
i was raised baptist um black baptist
coming from the midwest of the of the
country but
i think all religions are beautiful i'm
also aware
that religion historically including
today
in present times is used to oppress
people
these are numbers and that's not
that's something that we have to come to
terms with right and so
that's important is that you can come to
a table with people who
are nothing like you and regardless if
you agree or disagree with them
you can look at them like a human and
say but i want to actively listen to
your story
because all of us have stories and our
stories directly
come from our experiences
right um to give you an example i was on
instagram a few nights ago and i was
actually reading this thing from this
person that i went to high school with
um and she is clearly anti-abortion she
is pro-life
and i was just reading her stance um i
don't agree with her stance i am
pro-choice um and i'd like to say that
pro-choice is not pro-abortion it's just
pro-choice for me it's a ideology that
people have a right to choose what they
want to do with their bodies and that's
none of my business
and i should not be involved in it but i
agree with you interesting conversation
in the comments
with this woman that i think she went to
college with and i don't know this woman
where this woman was very upset by this
person's beliefs
and what i came from the conversation
was wouldn't it be interesting
if both of these people just sat at a
table
and had a conversation of why they
believe what they believe
yes does it i mean yeah beliefs are
valid
right and this and especially in america
right now this like
pro-life and pro-choice conversation is
an historic conversation i don't want
people to think that i don't think that
it's a very important conversation
um especially right now what's going on
today
on the senate floor um exactly today
exactly today it started a couple hours
ago on the senate floor
um but what happens when we can all just
sit there
and not just say okay so you believe
this but say so why do you believe this
right where does this come from and that
doesn't mean that when we finish this
conversation i'm going to agree to your
belief
but at the very basic level when we
finish this conversation i'm going to
see you as a human
right exactly to that point i have to
bring this up because i had a show
a few weeks ago with professor larry
diamond from stanford he was
one of my first professors he was
actually the very first professor i
walked into class on
my first day and which was called the
spirit of democracy and
and it was such a moving moment because
i brought up in that episode is because
10 minutes into class he started tearing
up when he was telling us about an
experiment him and
his colleague jim fishkin ran called
america in one room in texas they
brought together
a random sampling of of hundreds of
democrats independent
and and republicans and for three days
they had them deliberate
with moderators and regardless you know
the change in policies and the changing
thought that wasn't really interesting
to me because what
to me was really interesting was the
question that they asked is
they asked democrats how do you now
perceive your
the republicans across the table
republicans how do you perceive
democrats and
across the table the two groups started
seeing each other as humans and started
seeing each other as
thoughtful human beings and not as
enemies that are trying to destroy their
country
and to me that was very moving
unfortunately we don't see it
at a large scale yet but but they proved
that with what you're saying
that that's definitely something that's
that's extremely valuable
yeah i think that we all have to do that
right and not just in america right
i think every place is polarizing like
you're from israel i'm not gonna blow up
your spot but i'm sure you've had some
conversations um
about maybe one or more than a few
um right and just everywhere in the
world
and i think that we have to really just
come from this place of less of defense
and more of
why do you feel that way because when
you come from why do you feel that way
and then i see you as a human
then i'm opting in to maybe not
necessarily agreeing with you
but figuring out how can we come to a
middle ground
right i always tell people i am only
polarized on issues
that literally affect my humanity
right like if you believe that i should
not be a citizen
that's going to be like there is no
middle ground for that one if you
believe that i should not be alive there
is
no middle ground for that one if you
believe that i should be considered a
secondary
human there's no middle ground for that
one but other than that we can make a
lot work y'all
we can make a lot work um but yeah the
only the only thing that i can wish
that i can wish for us and everybody
else across the country that going into
this turmoil
of of a few months it's not even going
to be is
is to have you know proper discussions
and peaceful discussions
that's that's the one hope i have coming
out of this election i don't know how
feasible it is i think it's going to
heavily depend on on where the election
goes but
uh but but we can all hope to have a
little bit more humanity that's what i'm
taking out of this conversation
alexandra i want to thank you again so
much for being on the show you know i
had so many questions i wanted to ask
about
your different roles at twitter airbnb
and facebook but
you know the the the things that you're
talking about here i think are so
critical and so
you know incredibly important right now
for when we are so so thank you for
sharing
with me your insights and and the
amazing work that you've done before we
leave
i have to ask for three words that you
would use to describe yourself
the hardest question ever okay so my
first word is actually a phrase i'd
probably be freedom fighter
my second word would um
probably be accepting
and then my third word will probably be
curious i think all of those three
things when you put them all together
really encompasses who i
am in my professional and my personal
life right yeah
i want to know more about people and
yeah
i love it thank you so so much and this
is great and and
thank you for being on the show thank
you